all right this is uh this is fun and
scary at the same time i love a good
conspiracy theory many of you know i've
been fascinated by scams and
conspiracies since i was a kid
and i love seeing how do people get
convinced of jus
such wacky things that none of us should
be believing in
mlms and essential oils and all you know
all these different scam
products and all this different stuff
okay uh if you want to read a book by
the way
about large-scale scams and and uh cults
um and a lot of the a lot of scams are
also cultish
like with mlms that's often the case
check out the book
the road to jonestown about jim jones
and the people's temple and this is the
origin of the term to drink the kool-aid
it came tragically from
from the people's temple and jim jones
okay here is a conspiracy
that comes to us from newsmax which is
one of the two networks that donald
trump has been recommending as a truly
right-wing alternative to fox news
remember
trump and some of his most ardent
suck-up followers
have been attacking fox news lately as
being liberal now because they
acknowledge that joe biden won the
election that makes them liberal now
and the theory put forward by newsmax
and i'm using the word theory
in the colloquial sense not the
scientific sense
theory very loose colloquial usage we're
going to look at some clips in a moment
the theory is as follows
kamala harris senator from california
has not yet resigned her senate seat
even though kamala harris is the vice
president elect
and will be sworn in on january 20th she
is still a senator she's not resigned
and she can vote in the senate
and her senate term actually goes until
2023 if she were not to resign because
she's going to be vp at some point
between now and january 20th kamala
harris will resign
and that will clear the seat for
california governor gavin newsom to
select
a replacement the theory goes on newsmax
that the reason kamala harris hasn't
resigned
is because it's an insurance policy
because
deep down kamala knows she suspects
maybe she knows that it's actually not
going to be
joe biden sworn in on january 20th
deep down this is me this is not my view
right i'm telling you the theory
deep down kamala suspects trump
will be getting a second term not biden
so she's staying in the senate
so that when she doesn't become vice
president on january 20th
she can stay in the senate until january
of 2023
that's the theory let's check out some
clips this first one is a news max host
i don't know if it's pronounced
grant stinkfield or stinchfield
these are names we may have to become
familiar with as media critics for the
next couple of years
here is grant stinkfield exp explaining
what's going on with kamala
here's the reason they want senator
kamala harris
to be promptly inserted as president and
may i remind you
harris is a woman who has yet to resign
from the united states senate
in preparation of becoming the next vice
president and ultimately
president if the media gets their way
why hasn't she resigned
yet because maybe like all of us
she still thinks president trump has a
shot at victory
if only all the evidence of fraud can be
proven
and exposed so captioning not
a few days available to grant stinkfield
mentioning it take a listen
by the way i think the blind people
aren't as confident
as they are trying to convey you know
kamala harris has not resigned her seat
i'm told
uh yet in the united states senate
barack obama when he won back in 2008
he resigned before thanksgiving i think
they're
um just keeping their options open
depending on what happens so there's the
same idea from another newsmax host greg
kelly now
this this maybe could actually be
instructive anytime you're presented
with a conspiracy theory
you should know the process to go
through to
evaluate it and before you even start
evaluating the conclusions of the theory
you have to start with fact checking the
premises the first
question would be is it true that kamala
harris has not resigned from the senate
yet
that is true okay that's step one number
two
is it unusual that she hasn't resigned
yet halfway through december before
a january swearing-in well it is true
that barack obama
did resign his seat in mid-november in
2008 when he won
the presidential election that part is
true but what's unusual is how early
barack obama did it it's very unusual in
if you just go back to 2008 then senator
joe
biden didn't resign from the senate
until five days before he was
inaugurated as vp
in 2009. george w bush didn't resign as
texas governor
until late december in the year 2000.
bill clinton didn't resign as governor
of arkansas in 1992
until very late december al gore
didn't resign as senator until january
of 1993 even later than bill clinton
when al gore was set to become the vice
president
george h.w bush's vice president dan
quayle
didn't resign from the senate until
january
of uh the inauguration so there's
nothing unusual going on here and that's
where the conspiracy theory falls apart
it's predicated on everybody else has
resigned so early
no no no the truth is almost nobody
has already resigned in mid-december
when they are set to be inaugurated as
president or vp
in late january of the following year so
the most
likely reason why kamala harris is not
yet resigning
is that number one typically that's how
it works so she's doing what most
other people do and number two she wants
to be able to vote in the senate because
it's not clear how quickly california
governor gavin newsom will be ready to
replace her and you don't want to have
an empty seat in the senate
when democrats want to have as many
votes as possible including possibly on
very important things
like a second coronavirus stimulus
package so this is another
very silly conspiracy theory and we are
likely to hear
many more of them on newsmax and on oan
and i'm sure on fox news as well
over the next two to four years and in
fact i want to go
next to talk about fox news briefly
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
an excellent company
shipping is just five bucks and shipping
is free
on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david